hey listen Jocko I know that keeping the
ego in check is an important principle I
read about it extreme ownership you talk
about it all the time got to be humble
but at my company ego is a huge problem
how do I get my company to start
promoting the ideal of humility and how
do I get them to recognize that ego is
such a big problem now this is a really
good question once again because you can
imagine what this individual's right
like you know you're at a company where
there's a lot of egos going on and all
of a sudden you have a little moment of
enlightenment you realize that ego is
causing you a lot of problems so you
start putting your own ego in check and
then you go how this is working I'm
doing better I'm coordinating better I'm
working in my interpersonal
relationships with the other people on
the team are better my relationships
with people on other teams are better
we're getting more done because our
relationships are better
I'm putting the team and the mission
above myself that means the team in the
mission are doing better that's great so
you realize all this stuff and then you
say okay well how do I start to spread
the word how do I get other people to do
this and this is a tricky question right
it's a tricky thing because if some if
like let's say your team has you see
that ego is a problem and you sit him
down and go listen guys you're you're
all you all got big egos and that's the
problem
I mean you're gonna run into level 9
defensiveness you're actually gonna it's
actually go beyond offensiveness they're
gonna start attacking you now just gonna
happen you got all these crazy egos
they're gonna gang up there likes unites
they'll put their egos aside for a split
second so that can unite against you so
you can't confront them and and once
again
are there certain relationships that you
can have with someone where I go and if
let's say you and me and you had a ego
and put you and I were really tighten I
said hey man you're letting your ego get
in the way of this sure that kid that
that is a possibility that is a very
rare occurrence most of the people that
you work with on a regular basis you
don't have that type of a relationship
the other thing is when someone has a
big ego that's not the type of person
that's open to those kind of criticisms
anyways so it's like there's two two
hurdles that you have to overcome number
one your relationship isn't usually that
good at number two they have a big ego
which is part of the problem and that's
what makes the problem hard to attack
mm-hmm so what are you gonna do in in
what I gotta throw this one more little
thing when people talk about the you
know have someone say put put wouldn't
it be better if you could just talk to
him wouldn't it be better if you just
you know put down on some bullet eyes
list and said hey here's the things that
your ego there's the problems that you
guys are problem causing look I get it
and isn't it great to have direct
conversation isn't it great if I can
just sit you down if echo if you and I
have this mind meld where you just know
one hundred-percent looking out for you
and you're open to great like if we have
that that's in an ideal world that's
great mmm-hmm that's great golf claps
it's great the problem is it doesn't
exist very often and confronting someone
that has an ego about the Ricoh can
often just exacerbate the problem yeah
so here's what you do instead of self
identifying the problem and pointing the
fingers at other people which by the way
is placing blame which is a problem so
instead of doing that what we're gonna
do is start pulling the thread on some
of the problems that we're having on the
team so for instance this group over
here needs some help on their part of
the project but no one's helping them
what's going on if you start to pull the
thread on that you'll find at the end of
that thread they'll be hanging some egos
whether it's the ego of the person that
doesn't want to ask for help or whether
it's the ego of the other person that
doesn't want to give help because they
think they need to do their own job
that's oh I'm not gay I'm not doing that
mmm so you pull the thread and at the
end you'll find these little egos
hanging and then what you do is you just
expose and you say
what do you think the root of the
problem isn't you start pulling that
thread and you get to a point where
someone says you can finally have an
open conversation where you say where
someone finally says we no I I guess I I
guess I could use some help you just
discovered it so that's like a cover and
move situation right if the cover and
move isn't happening and it isn't
happening because of egos if you pull
the thread you'll get to the end of the
thread and it will be attached to
someone ego in most cases is there a
possibility that it's like hey this
group doesn't know what the other groups
don't yeah absolutely
those are but those are easy problems to
solve cuz we can just pull the thread we
find at the end oh we need to we need
better coordination between these two
teams cool there it is when you pull the
friend it comes out the the little egos
dangling on the end of it then you go
okay let's expose these and let's try
and ask questions to figure out and get
people to realize what they're looking
at hmm you want them to come to that
conclusion that's the trick
that's the maneuver is to get them to
come to a conclusion and they might
never verbalize it but they go you know
in their mind they're like I guess I
didn't want to ask for help in the way
so there's one you know if you got
people that are taking aren't keeping
things simple just go through the laws
combat simple make people are making the
plans too complex and yet they keep
doing it and they're when it when you go
and say you know these plans seem like
they're really complex and of course
they say something like hey that I don't
think everyone understood the plan
seemed to be it seemed kind of complex
and the person says people need to pay
more attention went on briefing and you
pull on that right the frontline troops
they need more detail because they
otherwise they're gonna screw up that's
why it's so complex it's like okay let's
look at what's really happening what's
really happening is I've created a plan
that I won't give up because my ego is
too big right when you pull that thread
and you go listen - hey the the
frontline troops don't understand what
to do it's
like that could be a real problem mm-hmm
and and maybe and there's nothing you
give them a little out you give me a
little out like you know maybe we just
need to back it off a little bit so that
they can understand it maybe they're not
as smart as yeah little Eagle massage
because it's fine you don't want fine
I'll simplify it boom and in the
meantime you've given them a little
indication look if you confront them
that's what I'm saying it's hard for
people who want to play the long game
here because the short game is it you're
you're you think you're so smart your
plants do complex and you're sticking
with them because you've got a big ego
how's that gonna work out he's not gonna
work out good can it work out 4% of the
time yes the other the other 96% of the
time you get a defensive person that's
now accusing other people it's take the
indirect and play the long game take the
indirect attack and play the longer
prioritize and execute right why is that
failing because again this question is
egos a problem so where does ego
manifest as a problem it can manifest as
a problem in in prioritize and execute
because if someone's got a big ego and
they're not getting things done and they
go I can get it done because their ego
thinks they can do anything right or
prioritize connects execute ego can be a
problem if you have a project and I have
a project and you need help and your
project is actually more important and I
should give you resources but instead of
like my initiative just as important as
Echo's is yeah which is just my ego I
should look at it and say okay you know
what you should be the priority and
another good one is yeah well it's just
what I just said like hey I'm not gonna
give up why should I have to give my
resources to echo those are mine no
actually what's the what's the biggest
priority okay put my ego aside
Echo's priority is actually bigger than
mine I'm gonna give him four of my
people so that he can get the job done
so when you pull the thread on this and
you say well hey hey why is it jakka why
is it you don't want to give people to
echo and I'm like well you know what if
something else comes up
else comes up you can get back well you
know that they gotta learn to respect
the chain of command well there's still
work for you they'll just be loaned over
to echo whoa you see them saying yes
it's just ego ego ego ego so these are
the kind of problems that manifests
themselves inside of a company wrapped
around ego mm-hmm and decentralized
command you can have the same thing
happen with decentralized command
how does he go cause a problem with
decentralized command it's like this hey
I noticed that um you know you seem to
be making all the decisions and the
folks out in the field don't really have
the opportunity to kind of make calls
why is that I'm the only one that has
the experience to do this they don't
have the skill that I have right so
there's all these reasons that that's
one of those are ego problems right and
and by the way if it's if it's not an
ego problem then then then I say oh you
know what because I haven't really
trained that guys well enough and I'm
gonna you know what you're right I've
been making way too many detailed
decisions for the guys out in the field
I need to get down there make sure they
know what's going on train them better
so that I can back off cool that's a
person that's got their ego check the
person that's like I'm the only one that
can do this like no you can't you know
you're not and if you are you're wrong
because right now you got three people
working for you what happens when you
have eight you're gonna go around the
field in all these different locations
to make every single decision no you
can't mm-hm so get your ego under
control realize that you're not the only
one that can do this job and train your
people properly again that's a direct
assault probably going to cause problems
instead if we just pull the thread on it
hey what's going on well it seems like
your folks down the field don't have a
lot of authority well you know they
don't experience oh okay you it's kind
of cumbersome though like them reaching
back to you all the time to make these
decisions it is but you know I'm the one
that really knows how to do it huh I
mean what happens if you know you're
sick or you know you someone's gotta you
know have communications with them do
you think it would be a good idea you
know since you have so much knowledge
and experience to maybe pass that on to
some of the other people
oh yeah okay cool let's make that happen
and then obviously ego can absolutely
manifest itself when it comes to taking
ownership I mean all day long right
what other that project failed what
happened would my subordinates don't
know don't want to step up okay so
therefore why what why are your
subordinates taking ownership cuz they
don't even know what ownership is didn't
want to take ownership okay so it's not
your fault no okay well what can we do
to help them mm-hmm pull the string and
you at the bottom the person will see
it's the rego they might not admit it
but they'll see it and then they can
start to make adjustments now look can
any of these situations escalate in a
point where in direct indirect in direct
indirect doesn't work and eventually you
say you know what well I gotta go I
gotta sit echo down and say listen
here's what I think is the root of the
problem the root of the problem is you
think you're the only one that knows how
to do this and in thinking that you're
not training to be like I might have to
get that direct it does happen we prefer
to use the minimum force required
required when it comes to leadership
just like being a bouncer yes sir right
it's not hey the guy's a little out of
line
hit him in the head with a blackjack no
it's like hey hey sir you know I think
you've had enough for tonight okay can
you come with me that's minimum force
Ricard if the guy says okay cool it's
problem solved if he's if he sees you
I'm not going anywhere
okay well we have to escalate it's the
same thing here but don't start with the
direct attack mm-hmm just like you don't
Club the person out of the gate
I think it's a slapjack I'm not sure
yeah okay that's what you're talking
about that young as their thing yeah
yeah a blackjack yeah blackjack yeah did
you guys not use those that's silly I
think those are illegal to that legal
yeah yeah the slapjack one guy had one
but yeah very illegal so we don't want
to
escalate straight to the blackjack or
even a slapjack even if anyone's using a
slapjack I think it's called a slap yeah
okay I'm not sure point remains I dig it
fairly confident you're wrong but not
100% yeah I'm like I'm like you know in
someone you know when you're pretty
confident about something that somebody
who just throws a little randomness into
the soup and it makes you question yeah
yeah that's how I feel right now yeah
that's real confident with a little bit
of questions it makes you feel any
better that's my everyday life so that's
the answer to this question is really
pulling the thread on the problem to
reveal the root of the problem which
you're gonna see is ego and then it's
there for the people hopefully to see it
to recognize it - possibly admit it
maybe not give them an out where they
can actually make an adjustment without
taking the ownership the Eagle because
that's okay yeah we're trying to win
right we're trying to let the team win
we're not trying to we're not yet what
my goal is not to make you admit it cuz
you know what that is that's my ego oh
yeah sure yeah it's got a big yeah get
him to a minute that's not my goals my
goal is to make you make better
decisions as a leader so that we win as
a team yeah so that's what we're that's
what we're trying to do here it's really
interesting that how you laid that out
cuz used to do that to me no probably
still do but it was less about the ego I
think anyway and maybe it's all the same
maybe at the end of the it's all the
same because skating you're trying to
dancer right so explain to me how I
would do this - you do with the excuses
okay so like if something didn't get
done or can't get done or I think it's
too hard and really most of the time if
I'm remembering correctly it was at the
end of the a this is what it was it was
like I'm too lazy or whatever you know
so it always be like this excuse like
well you know that's this or that's that
and then you'd have all these just like
how you're saying and I and it it made
me remember this because of your tone
how you're like kind of saying those
little
that's the same things with me like no
simple just like pull just here here's
the solution to that problem right here
because there's all these little excuses
that you make you know like oh I didn't
really have time because I had to do
this and you'd be like okay then you
just do this you know and that'll solve
that particular problem you didn't have
this big comprehensive plan to solve in
my life problem you're like okay for
every excuse oh and make you just have
the little solve you know the problem or
the solution to it and I'd be like man
and meanwhile you're getting backed into
this corner or the string is just
getting pulled like every with every
pool is lazy oh yeah like I just was too
lazy or I'm just like stuck in this
routine or whatever and then it so it
could in a way be like okay that's just
my ego just thinking that the way that's
not the way I do things kind of thing
and and think if I were to use the
different tone well think if I would
have just said that's good you're lazy
oh yeah yeah you just being lazy Aiko
yeah you've been like do you even know
what it takes to make one of these
things oh you don't know me and then all
of a sudden we and what does that do to
our relationship yeah and what does that
do to to to the final product
yeah yeah right now you're doing
something against your will stainless
stain on it yeah fully in the if you
would have just been like hey you're
lazy this is what my mind would have
went to this belief this actually and in
a way it's true but it doesn't like get
anyone anywhere where if you would be
like you're lazy I would have thought
and maybe even said that it's not that
I'm lazy it's just you're just this
crazy hard worker who have these
standards that are unreasonable for a
normal person and I'm just a normal
person excuse me you know kind of an
attitude that's what I would go to
rather than if you like the way how you
always do it is like you pull the string
or you just sort of you don't say no
it's interesting to us when I'm doing
that I'm not doing that
like okay I got here's my next move on
that go yeah actually what I'm doing is
like well you know you say well we can't
I can't make a video because it's gonna
take me too long to get through the the
raw edits and I go you know I said like
what you know if you want just get you
you know hire someone to do those raw
edits for you
would that work yeah you know what I
mean oh I'm asking you a legitimate
question oh yeah maybe I kind of know
the answer I mean I suspect I know the
answer but it's not it's not just hey I
I'm setting you up I'm legitimately
pulling the thread yeah and the answer
might be it is impossible to get this
project done but when I say well you
could hire someone to do those right
that's and then you go okay well even if
I hire someone how am I going to
transfer all this data and I go well if
you want what couldn't you get an
external hard drive and and just
physically give it to him yeah and you'd
say well these are actual situations no
no no I don't know the realm of video
well the main the one that I remember
the easiest is like with training like
you'll be hey we're training at 4:30 but
I trained during the day most evening
oh not in the evening then you'll be
like oh yeah train at 4:30 I'm like well
you know and I have all these reasons
and then you like you kind of just chip
away at all these reasons like oh here's
the solution to that is a solution a
solution that's like man I just that's
just like my routine I just gotta admit
it you know like I and but I don't get
to train with you guys as often you know
kind of thing but it's like yeah you
expose you pull the string to expose
just like the little the little excuses
Chuck so pull the thread reveal the
problem don't confront if you can help
it and people will start to recognize
what the problem is I mean this is
assuming you're working with this well
doesn't want this one problem with this
and that is if the person has a giant
ego that this is the hardest thing for
them to admit right so they might not
admit it but they'll see it they'll
behave differently and by the way one of
the good ways to to use someone's ego
against themselves is when you say
something along the lines of you know
man it's gonna look good if this gets
done right
you know what I'm saying and they think
oh cool I'm gonna do this I'm gonna make
this adjustment just so it gets done
just so my ego can get just so I can win
yeah that doesn't say that use the word
win because every time like use the word
win and any time what I'd be thinking
like okay if I didn't win whatever you
know what's left you lost
yeah no matter what excuse you make you
lost so if you put if you put the shed
light on like use that word and be like
hey this will make you win and you're
like hell yeah but at the same time the
vacuum mind like basically if we don't
solve these problems or whatever I lose
I don't want that so it's like extra
motivate the it's the winning at all
cost thing and so the winning at all
costs I wrote like a little section and
it was a part of a one of the special
releases on Barnes and Nobles version of
dichotomy a leadership was this thing
winning at all costs and it's and then
someone posted and I had I had said it
before right and someone posted a clip
of me saying this idea of winning at all
costs and it's the way that I talk about
it it's kind of a trick anyways because
I go through this thing about what is
leadership and AG leadership as this
leadership to that and I said what
leadership is to me is winning at all
costs and somebody put that probably you
put a clip up of me saying that and
somebody said of course someone's like
that's the kind of person that will run
people over and like it was like gave a
negative things right but what they
don't realize is what the rest of that
clip says and what the rest of that
whole idea of winning at all costs is
what I'll do it want to win it all costs
is totally subordinate my ego help other
people support them give them what they
need and put my foot put the team and
the mission above myself cuz the moat
that's how I'm gonna win at all costs so
winning at all cost doesn't mean I'm
stepping on other people
it means of actually lifting other
people up that's what it means
so if you can use that you know if I say
hey echo man look we need to win and you
if we're gonna win the only way to win
is if you can learn how to work with Jim
otherwise we lose and you're like you
know what because I'm a winner I'll work
with Jim cool it's a first step
yeah yeah